now Pakistan's former prime minister
Imran Khan is scheduled to appear in
court in Islamabad he faces corruption
charges in connection to a university
trust he and his wife run now a large
number of police have now left the
vicinity of his residence in Lahore
after spending most of Wednesday outside
his home
the 70 year old veteran politician has
said police were preparing to detain him
again
Pakistan Supreme Court has ruled his
arrest last week was illegal his
detention sparked violent protests
across the country
well earlier Imran Khan told Al
jazeera's opponents are trying to
prevent him from taking part in the next
elections
neither the military establishment which
means one man nor these 12 parties
they're too scared for elections because
they're scared I will win so because of
that
uh you know they're doing everything to
make sure that I get out of the race I
have had two assassination attempts on
me one was where I was hit one where I I
was lucky to be alive because it just
you know I got saved thank God so this
is the issue 150 cases on me someone who
has not had one criminal case in last
few months has 150 cases including 15
criminal cases in a day 40 terrorist
cases so I mean this is how to get me
out of the race
let's go to Kamal harder who's live for
us in Islamabad Kamar will Imran Khan
appear in court today
first of all he was supposed to appear
before the national accountability
Bureau and that Al-Qaeda trust case
which involved his wife and the former
prime minister or alleged to be involved
in that scam however because of the
situation evolving at Damon Park in
Residence he is unable to come to Islam
about today so he will not be attending
that Court as you saw the police have
been withdrawn because after the
government of the Punjab issued an
ultimatum which is likely to expire in
less than two hours that he should hand
over 30 to 40 terrorists who were hiding
at Zaman park that is Imran Khan's
residence the former prime minister said
that he called the media to come and see
for themselves the local and
international media and said that the
police should come with a warrant and
search the place and find out whether
there are any eternity is not because
they would not just be a threat to the
government but also to the former prime
minister so indeed uh 10 situations
still prevailing we'll have to wait and
see what happens at two o'clock local
time which is about nine GMT and after
that expiry of the ultimatum whether the
authorities will try to arrest him or to
go into that place of course the
authorities have also now indicated that
they would like they would have the
media there as well so interesting
developments and we'll have to wait and
see what happens within the next few
hours
yeah I mean difficult for you to
speculate but I mean what are the
options available to the government I
mean what could their next move be
well first of all it is interesting to
note that the president of Pakistan Dr
Arif alway uh said yesterday that all
sides should take a deep breath and try
to reach a negotiated settlement earlier
the Supreme Court had asked the ruling
Coalition and Imran Khan's party members
to sit together to hammer out some sort
of a consensus on the forthcoming
elections which are due in October after
the government disobeyed or disregarded
the orders of the Supreme Court to hold
hold provincialism as elections in the
Punjab which were due to be held on the
30th of April were delayed till the 14th
of May but did not happen so all sides
will have to rethink their strategies
people in Pakistan are saying they don't
want their politicians to become
generals or their generalists to become
politicians that all sides should sit
together reach and negotiated settlement
the countries in a crisis and economical
economic political and constitutional
crisis which is untenable so all sides
have to take a deep breath as the
president suggested thank you for that
come on hi to their first live in
Islamabad